[Music]
are you up on social media maybe you can
use a smartphone I do I have a
smartphone and I love social media and
you know it's addictive but it's it's
weird people seem to just send me photos
of white guys that look like me you know
like the the Boris Johnson guy probably
got in like 15 the British PM yeah Boris
Johnson yeah
say you look like yeah you probably get
a lot of people just I wish I had that
much hair yeah I have people come up to
me all the time and they say people say
that I'm like it's funny we met cuz
people say we're identical and they have
reddish hair but other than that they
look nothing like me
they're you know what I mean they're
from South America I've got like a
little few whispers right here and
they're like everywhere I go yeah look
at us we're twins
I'm constantly get picture like old
pictures of babies old babies people are
like look it looks just like you like
your head the heads round you look like
do you look like albey yeah like yeah
like an archival baby I guess or people
just send me pictures of morbidly obese
people and they'll say this guy look
reminds me of you did you got a weird
one you got someone sent you a picture
and said what you look like a body part
well there was this woman standing there
and her knees the guy said that I look
like that my face is on these woman's
let's take a look I just want to see if
we can even see oh my god
[Laughter]
[Applause]
those are some good-looking knees yeah
you